just some breaking news for you this
evening and the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex have tonight confirmed that
they've been asked to vacate their UK
home Harry and Megan's spokesperson said
a request had been made for the sussexes
to give up Frogmore Cottage of course
which is in the grounds of Windsor
Castle
reports have claimed the move was
sanctioned by King Charles that breaking
news this evening coming from a
spokesperson for Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle that move is said to have been
sanctioned by the king it will remove
their remaining foothold in the UK and
of course that comes ahead of King
Charles's coronation on May the 6th
still no word whether Prince Harry and
the Duchess of Sussex will attend the
coronation but that breaking news this
evening coming from a spokesperson for
Harry and Megan that they have been
asked to give up their home in the UK
Frogmore Cottage in Windsor Castle